we're here at blizzcon 2016 I'm Justin
and this is eric one of the biggest
announcements but also maybe the most
disappointing was the Diablo like I I
had a feeling we're going to get diablo
2 remastered Diablo for that's not what
happened we did get some an exciting
announcement though for fans of diablo 2
and that's the ability to place the
necromancer are you excited I I'm 41
okay ever since the leak happened I was
like okay that's not good I was hope I
was really hoping for one of two things
to get announced today which didn't
happen I want addy for some type of
teaser trailer didn't happen or diablo 2
remastered which also didn't happen so
now the necromancer is going to be in
diablo 3 in 2017 and the one other thing
that we found out today was that they're
going to have to celebrate the 20th
anniversary of diablo they're going to
bring back kind of like trish strim and
some of those old like eight way affects
instead of the 360 effects that diablo
one had into diablo 3 which I believe
that's actually out in PT our next week
but yeah so the necromancer is still
quite a ways off we're not going to
actually get to play him finally until
2017 but you did play a run through a
little bit it's a weird choice because
we already have which doctor in the game
so so what are your feelings on an
initial play through with necromancer
sure so we like you said we got to play
necromancer today unfortunately it was
kind of bare bones there were no runes
on any of his abilities he basically had
six bilities that you can currently use
that they had in the game one is a
fan-favorite that's returning which is
corpse explosion very fun um you
basically get to target like a small
area and that area if there is a corpse
air will explode and if there's multiple
corpses ocon chain explode so that's
really fun kind of curious to see what
the runes will do to it to like magnify
the explosions increase the area affect
things like that probably his main
ability to gain back essence or kind of
like mana is like a like a siphon blood
it basically channels kind of like
sucking of blood away from someone which
is kind of cool and again you know you
are necromancer so you have the Living
Dead on your side I guess you got to
have skeletons walking around with you
the melee versions and the caster
versions one of the abilities lets you
kind of seek them on to like one monster
which i guess is pretty effective if
you're trying to get the corpse
explosion and whatnot off so that's kind
of cool again curious what they do with
the runes in terms of how they enhance
the you know skeletons or that ability
and another staple moved decrepit by
basically a huge area of effect spell
that slows down and and like weakens
your opponents that you're fighting
against so pretty standard classic stuff
not that I'm not that excited I'm sure
some people are though so despite your
worries it does sound like it
distinguishes itself from which doctor
yeah sort of I mean again very
bare-bones build today hard hard for me
to say oh I forgot totally forgot bone
Spears also in the game so bonus fear is
pretty boring so it'll be cool to see
what they do with that cuz you know bone
spear looks the same kind of this is the
old bonus fear but with ruins everything
looks crazy right so who knows I think
it's a weird choice I feel like it's
almost like a stall tactic in a way you
know so what to see where we get to next
year I guess yeah it's weird that we're
bringing this back who's diablo 3 has
been out for a while is this something
that's gonna bring you back to playing
diablo 3 um the trim event which we
found out is now in January of yearly
will get me to play again I think just
to experience that experience the sound
effects and just kind of dabble with
that again because it's just fun and
nostalgic the necromancer stuff I'll
probably play it because there were
probably some other updates around the
game I don't know if I'll necessarily
make a necromancer I mean I don't really
want to but I guess that's the only kind
of new part of the game sands some of
the content so we'll see I'm a sucker
for Diablo what can I say so the tryst
from Diablo 1 content is going to be on
PTR soon and it's going to be launching
in January it's going to be a yearly
event after that and we're going to get
two plays necromancer sometime in 2017
do you want to read more about that and
watch more stay tuned to gamespot com
[Music]
you
[Music]